ANNOUNCER: The following content
is provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT Open Courseware
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JULIAN SHUN: All right.
So today we're going
to talk about cache
oblivious algorithms.
Who remembers what a cache
oblivious algorithm is?
So what is a cache oblivious
algorithm oblivious to?
Cache size.
So a cache oblivious
algorithm is an algorithm
that automatically tunes for
the cache size on your machine.
So it achieves good
cache efficiency.
And the code doesn't need to
have any knowledge of the cache
parameters of your machine.
In contrast, a
cache-aware algorithm
would actually know the
parameters of the cache sizes
on your machine.
And the code would actually put
the size of the cache inside.
So today we're going to talk a
lot more about cache oblivious
algorithms.
Last time we talked about
one cache oblivious algorithm
that was for matrix
multiplication.
And today we're going to
talk about some other ones.
So first example I
want to talk about
is simulation of heat diffusion.
So here's a famous equation
known as the heat equation.
And this equation is
in two dimensions.
And we want to
simulate this function
u that has three parameters t,
x, and y. t is the time step.
X and y are the x, y
coordinates of the 2D space.
And we want to know the
temperature for each x,
y coordinate for
any point in time t.
And the 2D heat
equation can be modeled
using a differential equation.
So how many of you have seen
differential equations before?
OK.
So good, most of you.
So here I'm showing the
equation in two dimensions.
But you can get
similarly equations
for higher dimensions.
So here it says the partial
derivative of u with respect
to t is equal to alpha.
Alpha is what's called
the thermo diffusivity.
It's a constant times the sum
of the second partial derivative
of u with respect to x, and the
second partial derivative of u
with respect to y.
So this is a pretty
famous equation.
And you can see that we
have a single derivative
on the left side and a double
derivative on the right side.
And how do we
actually write code
to simulate this
2D heat process?
So oftentimes in
scientific computing,
people will come up with these
differential equations just
to describe physical processes.
And then they want to come
up with efficient code
to actually simulate
the physical process.
OK.
So here's an example
of a 2D heat diffusion.
So let's say we started out with
a configuration on the left.
And here the color
corresponds to a temperature.
So a brighter color
means it's hotter.
Yellow is the hottest
and blue is the coldest.
In on the left we
just have 6172,
which is the course number.
So if you didn't
know that, you're
probably in the wrong class.
And then afterwards
we're going to run it
for a couple time steps.
And then the heat is going
to diffuse to the neighboring
regions of the 2D space.
So after you run it
for a couple of steps,
you might get the
configuration on the right
where the heat is
more spread out now.
And oftentimes, you want
to run this simulation
for a number of time steps
until the distribution of heat
converges so it
becomes stable and that
doesn't change by much anymore.
And then we stop the simulation.
So this is the 1D heat equation.
I showed you a 2D one earlier.
But we're actually going to
generate code for the 1D heat
equation since it's simpler.
But all the ideas generalize
to higher dimensions.
And here's the range of colors
corresponding to temperature,
so the hottest
colors on the left
and the coldest
colors on the right.
And if you had a
heat source that's
on the left hand
side of this bar,
then this might possibly
be a stable distribution.
So if you keep running
the simulation,
you might get a stable
distribution of heat
that looks like this.
OK.
So how do we actually write code
to simulate this differential
equation?
So one commonly used method
is known as finite difference
approximation.
So we're going to approximate
the partial derivative of u
with respect to each
of its coordinates.
So the partial derivative
of u with respect to t
is approximately equal
to u of t plus delta t
where delta t is some small
value, and x, and then
minus u of tx.
And then that's all
divided by delta t.
So how many of you have seen
this approximation method
before from your calculus class?
OK, good.
So as you bring the value
of delta t down to 0,
then the thing on the
right hand side approach
is the true partial derivative.
So that's a partial
derivative with respect to t.
We also need to get the partial
derivative with respect to x.
And here I'm saying the
partial derivative with respect
to x is approximately
equal to ut of x plus delta
x over 2 minus ut
of x minus delta x
over 2, all divided by delta x.
So notice here that
instead of adding delta
x in the first term
and not adding anything
in the second term, I'm
actually adding delta x over 2
in the first term and
subtracting text over 2
in the second term.
And it turns out that I can
do this with the approximation
method.
And it still turns out to be
valid as long as the two terms
that I'm putting in, their
difference is delta x.
So here the
And I can basically
decide how to split up
this delta x term among the
two things in the numerator.
And the reason why I
chose delta x over 2 here
is because the math is just
going to work out nicely.
And it's going to
give us cleaner code.
This is just the first partial
derivative with respect to x.
Actually need the second
partial derivative
since the right hand
side of this equation
has the second
partial derivative.
So this is what the second
partial derivative looks like.
So I just take the partial
derivative with respect
to x of each of the terms in
my numerator from the equation
above.
And then now I can
actually plug in the value
of this partial derivative
by applying the equation
above using the arguments
t and x plus delta x
over 2, and similarly
for the second term.
So for the first
term when I plug it
into the equation for the
partial derivative with respect
to x, I'm just going to get ut
of x plus delta x minus utx.
And then for the
second term, I'm
going to get ut of
x minus delta x.
And then I subtract
another factor of utx.
So that's why I'm subtracting
2 times utx in the numerator
here.
And then the partial
derivative of each
of the things in
a numerator also
have to divide by
this delta x term.
So on the denominator,
I get delta x squared.
So now I have the second partial
derivative with respect to x.
And I also have the first
partial derivative with respect
to t.
So I can just plug them
into my equation above.
So on the left hand side I
just have this term here.
And I'm multiplying by
this alpha constant.
And then on this term
just comes from here.
So this is what the
1d heat equation
reduces to using the finite
difference approximation
method.
So any questions on this
So how do we actually write code
to simulate this equation here?
So we're going to use what's
called a stencil computation.
And here I'm going to set delta
at x and delta t equal to 1,
just for simplicity.
But in general you can set
them to whatever you want.
You can make them
smaller to have
a more fine grained simulation.
So my set delta x and
delta eat t equal to 1.
Then the denominators of these
two terms just become one
and I don't need to
worry about them.
And then I'm going
to represent my 2D
space using a 2D matrix where
the horizontal axis represents
values of x, and the vertical
axis represents values of t.
And I want to fill
in all these entries
that have a black dot in it.
The ones with the orange
dot, those are my boundaries.
So those actually fixed
throughout the computation.
So I'm not going to do
any computation on those.
Those are just given
to me as input.
So they could be
heat sources if we're
doing the heat simulation.
And then now I can
actually write code
to simulate this equation.
So if I want to compute u of t
plus 1x, I can just go up here.
And I see that that's equal
to this thing over here.
And then I bring the negative
utx term to the right.
So I get ut of x
plus alpha times ut
x plus 1 minus 2 times
utx plus ut x minus 1.
As I said before, we just
want to keep iterating this
until the temperatures
becomes stable.
So I'm going to proceed in time,
which in time is going up here.
And to compute one
of these points--
so let's say this
is ut plus 1x--
I need to know the value
of utx, which is just
a thing below me in the matrix.
And I also need to know
utx plus 1 and utx minus 1.
And those are just
the things below me
and diagonal to either the
left or the right side.
So each value here just
depends on three other values.
And this is called a
three point stencil.
This is the pattern that this
equation is representing.
And in general, a
stencil computation
is going to update each point in
an array using a fixed pattern.
This is called a stencil.
So I'm going to
do the same thing
for all of the other points.
And here, I'm going to
compute all the values
of x for a given time step.
And then I move on to
the next time step.
And then I keep doing this
until the distribution
of temperatures becomes stable.
And then I'm done.
OK.
So these stencil
computations are widely
used in scientific computing.
They're used for weather
simulations, stock market
simulations, fluid dynamics,
image processing probability,
and so on.
So they're used all over
the place in science.
So this is a very
important concept to know.
So let's say I just ran
the code as I showed you
in the animation.
So I completed one row at
a time before I moved on
to the next row.
How would this code perform
with respect to caching?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I think if
x is less than a third
of the cache size, [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah.
So if x is small, this
would do pretty well.
But what if x is much larger
than the size of your cache?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah, you.
Would do badly and why is that?
AUDIENCE: Because the whole
[INAUDIBLE] second row,
[INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah.
So it turns out that there
could be some reuse here,
because when I compute
the second row,
I'm actually using
some values that
are computed in the first row.
But if the row is much
larger than the cache size,
by the time I get
to the second row,
the values that I loaded
into cache from the first row
would have been evicted.
And therefore, I'm going to
suffer a cache miss again
for the second row, for the
values I need to load in,
even though they could have been
used if we made our code have
good locality.
Another question I
have is if we only
cared about the values of x
at the most recent time step,
do we actually have to keep
around this whole 2D matrix?
Or can we get by
with less storage?
Yeah.
So how many rows would
I have to keep around
if I only cared about the
most recent time step?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Two.
JULIAN SHUN: Two.
And why is that?
AUDIENCE: So one for
the previous time step.
One for the current time step.
[INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN SHUN: Right.
So I need to keep around
two rows because I
need the row from the
previous time step
in order to compute the values
in the current time step.
And after the
current time step, I
can just swap the
roles of the two rows
that I'm keeping
around, and then
reuse the previous
row for the next one.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Would you
only need one and then
a constant amount
of extra space,
like if you had
three extra things,
you could probably
do it with one.
JULIAN SHUN: So I need to know--
when I'm computing
the second row,
I need to keep around
all of these values
that I computed
in the first row,
because these values
get fed to one
of the computations
in the second row.
So I need to actually
keep all of them around.
AUDIENCE: I think if you
iterate to the right,
then you have three that are
this one and the next one.
Just three.
Then you can--
JULIAN SHUN: Oh, I see I
see what you're saying.
Yeah.
So that's actually
a good observation.
So you only need to
keep a constant amount
more storage, because you'll
just be overwriting the values
as you go through the row.
So if you keep around one
row, some of the values
would be for the current
time step, and some of them
would be from the
previous time step.
So that's a good
observation, yes.
OK.
So that code, as we saw, it
wasn't very cache efficient.
You could make a cache
efficient using tiling.
But we're going to go straight
to the cache oblivious
algorithm because
it's much cleaner.
So let's recall the
ideal cache model.
We talked about this in
the previous lecture.
So here we have a
two level hierarchy.
We have a cache.
And then we have
the main memory.
The cache has size of M bytes.
And a cache line is B bytes.
So you can keep around M over
B cache lines in your cache.
And if something's in cache
and you operate on it,
then it doesn't incur
any cache misses.
But if you have to
go to main memory
to load the cache line in,
then you incur one cache miss.
The ideal cache model
assumes that the cache
is fully associative.
So any cache line can go
anywhere in the cache.
And it also assumes either an
optimal omniscient replacement
policy or the LRU policy.
So the optimal omniscient
replacement policy
knows the sequence of all
future requests to memory.
And when it needs
to evict something,
it's going to pick the thing
that leads to the fewest cache
misses overall to evict.
The LRU policy just
evict the thing
that was least recently used.
But we saw from the
previous lecture,
that in terms of
asymptotic costs,
these two replacement
policies will give you
cache misses within a
constant fact of each other.
So you can use either one,
depending on what's convenient.
And two performance
measures that we
care about when we're
analyzing an algorithm
and the ideal cache
model are the work
and the number of cache misses.
So the work is just the
total number of operations
that the algorithm incurs.
And serially, this is just
the ordinary running time.
And the number of cache misses
is the number of cache lines
you have to transfer between
the cache and your main memory.
So let's assume that
we're running an algorithm
or analyzing an algorithm
in the ideal cache model,
and it runs serially.
What kinds of cache misses
does the ideal cache model
not capture?
So remember, we talked about
several types of cache misses.
And there's one
type of cache miss
that this model doesn't capture
when we're running serially.
So let's assume we're
running this serially
without any parallelism here.
So the sharing misses
has only come about when
you have parallelism.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Conflictness?
JULIAN SHUN: Yes.
So the answer is conflictnesses.
And why is that?
Why does this model
not capture it?
AUDIENCE: There's
not a specific sets
that could get replaced then
since it's fully associated.
JULIAN SHUN: Yes.
So this is a fully
associative cache.
So any cache line can go
anywhere in the cache.
And you can only get conflict
misses for set associated
schemes where each
cache line can only
be mapped to a particular set.
And if you have too
many cache lines that
map to that particular
set, then you're
going to keep
evicting each other
even though the rest of
the cache could have space.
And that's what's
called a conflict miss.
The ideal cash model does
capture capacity misses.
So therefore, it is
still a very good model
to use at a high
level when you're
designing efficient
algorithms, because it
encourages you to optimize for
spatial and temporal locality.
And once you have a good
algorithm in the ideal cache
model then you can start
dealing with conflict misses
using some of the
strategies that we
talked about last
time such as padding
or using temporary memory.
So any questions on this?
OK.
So this is the code that
does the heat simulation
that we saw earlier.
So it's just two for
loops, a nested for loop.
In the outer loop, we're
looping over the time dimension.
In the inner loop, we're looping
over the space dimension.
So we're computing
all the values
of x before we move on
to the next time step.
And then we're
storing two rows here
and we're using this trick
called a even odd trick.
And here's how it works.
So to access the next row
that we want to compute,
that we just do
a t plus 1 mod 2.
And then to access the current
row, it's just t mod 2.
So this is implicitly going to
swap the roles of the two rows
that we're keeping around
as we progress through time.
And then we're
going to set u of t
plus 1 mod 2x equal
to kernel of u--
pointer to ut mod 2x.
And this kernel function
is defined up here.
And recall, that
when we're actually
passing a pointer to
this kernel function,
we can actually treat a pointer
as the beginning of an array.
So we're using array
notation up here
inside the kernel function.
So the array W is
passed as input.
And then we need
to return W of 0.
That's just the element
at the current pointer
that we passed to kernel.
And then we add alpha
times w of negative 1.
That's one element before the
thing that we're pointing to,
minus 2 times W
of 0 plus W of 1.
W of 1 is the next element
that we're pointing to.
OK.
So let's look at the caching
behavior of this code.
So we're going to analyze
the cache complexity.
And we're going to assume the
LRU replacement policy here,
because we can.
And as we said
before, we're going
to loop through one
entire row at a time
before we go onto the next row.
So the number of
cache misses I get,
assuming that n
is greater than M,
so that the row size is
greater than the cache
size, the number of cache
misses is theta of NT over B.
So how do I get this cache
complexity around here?
So how many cache
misses do I have
to incur for each row of this
2D space that I'm computing?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: N over B.
JULIAN SHUN: Right.
So I need N over B cache
misses for each row.
And this is because I can
load in B bytes at a time.
So I benefit from
spatial locality there.
And then I have N elements
I need to compute.
So it's theta of
N over B per row.
And as we said before, when
we get to the next row,
the stuff that we need
from the previous row
have already been
evicted from cache.
So I basically have to incur
theta of N over B cache
misses for every row.
And the number of rows
I'm going to compute as t.
So it's just theta of NT over B.
Any questions on this analysis?
So how many of you think
we can do better than this?
OK.
So one person.
Two, three.
OK.
So turns out that we
can do better than this.
You can actually do
better with tiling,
but I'm not going to
do the tiling version.
I want to do the cache
oblivious version.
And the cache
oblivious version is
going to work on trapezoidal
regions in the 2D space.
And recall that a trapezoid has
a top base and a bottom base.
And here the top base is at
t1, the bottom base is at t0,
and the height is
just t1 minus t0.
And the width of a trapezoid
is just the width of it
at the midpoint between t1 and
t0, so at t1 plus t0 over 2.
So we're going to
compute all of the points
inside this trapezoid
that satisfy
these inequalities here.
So t has to be greater than or
equal to t0 and less than t1.
And then x is greater than
or equal to x0 plus dx0
times t minus t0.
So dx0 is actually the
inverse slope here.
And then it also has
to be less than x1
plus dx1 times t minus t0.
So dx1 is the inverse
slope on the other side.
And dx0 and dx1 have to be
either negative 1, 0, or 1.
So negative 1 just corresponds
to inverse slope of negative 1,
which is also a
slope of negative 1.
If it's 1, then it's just
a slope or inverse of 1.
And then if it's 0, then we
just have a vertical line.
OK.
So the nice property
of this trapezoid
is that we can actually compute
everything inside the trapezoid
without looking
outside the trapezoid.
So we can compute everything
here independently
of any other trapezoids
we might be generating.
And we're going to
come up with a divide
and conquer approach
to execute this code.
So the divide and conquer
algorithm has a base case.
So our base case
is going to be when
the height of the
trapezoid is 1.
And when the height
is 1, then we're
just going to compute all of
the values using a simple loop.
And any order if the
computation inside this loop
is valid, since we
have all the values
in the base of the
trapezoid and we
can compute the values in
the top of the trapezoid
in whatever order.
They don't depend on each other.
So that's a base case.
Any questions so far?
So here's one of
the recursive cases.
It turns out that
we're going to have
two different types of cuts.
The first cut is
called a space cut.
So I'm going to do a space cut
if the width of the trapezoid
is greater than or equal
to twice the height.
So this means that the
trapezoid is too wide.
And I'm going to
cut it vertically.
More specifically, I'm
going to cut it with a line,
with slope negative 1
going through the center
of the trapezoid.
And then I'm going to traverse
the trapezoid on the left side
first.
And then after I'm
done with that,
traverse the trapezoid
on the right side.
So can I actually switch
the order of this?
Can I compute the
stuff on the right side
before I do this stuff
on the left side?
No.
Why is that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah.
So there some points
in the right trapezoid
that depend on the values
from the left trapezoid.
And so for the left trapezoid,
every point we want to compute,
we already have
all of its points,
assuming that we get all the
values of the base points.
But for the right hand
side, some of the values
depend on values in
the left trapezoid.
So we can't execute
the right trapezoid
until we're done with
the left trapezoid.
And this is the reason
why I cut this trapezoid
with a slope of
negative 1 instead
of using a vertical cut.
Because if I did a
vertical cut then
inside both of the
trapezoids, I would
have points that depend
on the other trapezoid.
So this is one of the two cuts.
This is called a space cut.
And it happens when the
trapezoid is too wide.
The other cut is
the time cut I'm
going to cut with respect
to the time dimension.
And this happens when the
trapezoid is too tall,
so when the width is less
than twice the height
of the trapezoid.
Then what I'm going
to do is I'm just
going to cut it with
a horizontal line
through the center.
And then I'm going to traverse
the bottom trapezoid first.
And after I'm done with that,
I can traverse a top trapezoid.
And again, the top trapezoid
depends on some points
from the bottom trapezoid.
So it's I can't switch
the order of those.
Any questions?
OK.
So let's now look
at the code that
implements this recursive
divide and conquer algorithm.
So here's the C code.
It takes as input t0 and t1.
These are the
coordinates of the top
and the bottom up the
trapezoid, or bottom and top
of the trapezoid, then x.
0 is the left side
of the trapezoid--
of the base of the trapezoid.
dx0 is the inverse
slope, and the x1
is the right side of the
bottom base of the trapezoid,
and dx1 is the inverse
slope on the right side.
So we're first going to compute
the height of our trapezoid.
And we're going to
let LT be the height.
And that's just t1 minus t0.
And if the height
is 1, then we're
just going to use a for
loop over all the points
in that height 1 trapezoid.
We're going to call
this kernel function
that we defined before.
And otherwise, the
height is greater than 1.
And we're going to check
whether we should do a space cut
or time cut.
So we do a space cut if
the trapezoid is too wide.
And this condition
inside the if clause
is checking if the
trapezoid is too wide.
And if so, then we're going
to make two recursive calls
to trapezoid.
And we're going to cut
it in the middle using
this slope of negative 1.
So you see the negative ones
here in the recursive calls.
And otherwise,
we'll do a time cut.
And for the time cut we
just cut it in the middle.
So we cut it at the value of t
that's equal to LT divided by,
2 or t0 plus LT divided by 2.
And again, we have two
recursive calls to trapezoid.
OK.
So even though I'm only
generating slopes of negative 1
in this recursive
call, this code
is going to work even if
I have slopes of 1 and 0,
because I could start out
with slopes of 1 and 0.
For example, if I had
a rectangular region,
then the slopes are
just going to be 0,
and this code is
still going to work.
But most of the slopes
that I'm dealing with
are going to be a
negative 1, because those
are the new slopes
and I'm generating.
Any questions?
So this code is very concise.
It turns out that even, odd
tricks still works here.
You can still keep
around just two rows,
because you're guaranteed
that you're not
going to overwrite any
value until all the things
that depend on it are computed.
But when you're
using just two rows,
the values in a particular
row might not all
correspond to the
same time step,
because we're not finishing
an entire row before we
move on to the next one.
We're actually partially
computing rows.
OK.
So let's analyze the cash
complexity of this algorithm.
Again, we're going to use
the recursion tree approach
that we talked about last time.
And our code is
going to split itself
into two cell problems at every
level until it gets to a leaf.
And each leaf represents
theta of hw points
where h is theta of w.
So h is the height.
w is the width.
And we have the property that
h is equal to theta w because
of the nature of the algorithm.
When the trapezoid
becomes too wide,
we're going to make it less
wide by doing a space cut.
And if it becomes
too tall, we're
going to do a horizontal cut.
So we're guaranteed that
the height and the width
are going to be within a
constant factor of each other
when we get to the base case.
And each leaf in
the base case is
going to incur theta
of w over B misses
because we have to load in
the base of the trapezoid
from main memory.
And once that's in
cache, we can compute
all of the other
points in the trapezoid
without incurring any
more cache misses.
So the cache misses per
leaf is just theta w over B.
And we're going to set w equal
to theta of M in the analysis,
because that's the point when
the trapezoid fits into cache.
The algorithm doesn't
actually have any knowledge
of this M parameter.
So it's still going
to keep divide
and conquering until it gets
the base case of size 1.
But just for the analysis,
we're going to use a base
case when w is theta of M.
So the number of leaves
we have is theta of NT
divided by w because each
leaf is a size theta hw.
The number of
internal notes we have
is equal to a number
of leaves minus
because we have a tree here.
But the internal notes don't
contribute substantially
to the cache complexity,
because each of them
is just doing a
constant number of cache
misses to set up the
two recursive calls.
And it's not doing anything
more expensive than that.
So we just need to compute
the number of cache
misses at the leaves.
We have theta of NT over hw
leaves, each one of which
takes theta of w
over B cache misses.
And we're going to
multiply that out.
So the w term cancels out.
We just have NT over hB and we
set h and w to be theta of M.
So we're just left with NT over
MB as our cache complexity.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Can you explain
why hB [INAUDIBLE]??
JULIAN SHUN: Sure.
So each leaf only incurs
theta w over B cache
misses because we need
to compute the values
of the base of the trapezoid.
And that's going to
incur theta of w over B
cache misses
because it's w wide,
and therefore, everything else
is going to fit into cache.
So when we compute
them, we already
have all of our previous
values that we want in cache.
So that's why it's not going
to incur any more cache misses.
So does that makes sense?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I forgot
that it was [INAUDIBLE]..
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah.
OK.
So this was just analysis
for one dimension.
But it actually generalizes
to more than one dimension.
So in general, if we
have d dimensions,
then the cache complexity
is going to be theta of NT
divided by M to the
1 over d times B.
So if d is 1, then that
just reduces to NT over MB.
If d is 2, then it's going to
be NT over B times square root
of M and so on.
And it turns out that this
bound is also optimal.
So any questions?
So compared to the
looping code, this code
actually has much
better cache complexity.
It's saving by a factor
of M. The looping code
had a cache complexity that
was theta of NT over B.
It didn't have an M
in the denominator.
OK.
So we're actually going
to do a simulation now.
We're going to compare
how the looping
code in a trapezoid code runs.
And in this simulation,
the green points
correspond to a cache hit,
the purple points correspond
to a cache miss.
And we're going assume a fully
associative cache using the LRU
replacement policy where the
cache line size is 4 points
and cache size is 32 points.
And we're going to set the cache
hit latency to be one cycle,
and the cache miss
latency to be 10 cycles.
So an order of magnitude
slower for cache misses.
And we're doing this
for a rectangular region
where N is 95.
And we're doing it
for 87 time steps.
So when we pull out
the simulation now.
OK.
So on the left hand side, we're
going to have the looping code.
On the right hand
side, we're going
to have the trapezoidal code.
So let's start this.
So you can see that
the looping code
is going over one row at a time
whereas the trapezoidal code is
not doing that.
It's partially computing
one row and then moving
on to the next row.
I can also show the
cuts that are generated
by the trapezoidal algorithm.
I have to remember
how to do this.
So C--
So there there's the
cuts that are generated
by the trapezoidal algorithm.
And I can speed this up.
So you can see that the
trapezoidal algorithm
is incurring much fewer cache
misses than the looping code.
So I just make this go faster.
And the trapezoid code
is going to finish,
while the looping code
is still slowly making
its way up the top.
OK.
So it's finally done.
So any questions on this?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Why doesn't the
trapezoid [INAUDIBLE]??
JULIAN SHUN: In
which of the regions?
So it's loading-- you get a
cache miss for the purple dots
here.
And then the cache
line size is 4.
So you get a cache miss
for the first point,
and then you hit on
the next three points.
Then you get another cache
miss for the fifth point.
And then you hit on
the 6, 7, and 8 points.
AUDIENCE: I was indicating
the one above it.
JULIAN SHUN: So for
the one above it--
so we're assuming that the two
arrays fitting cache already.
So we don't actually need
to load them from memory.
The thing above it just
depends on the values
that we have already computed.
And that fits in cache.
Those are ready in cache.
This base of the trapezoid
is already in cache.
And the row right
above it, we just
need to look at those values.
Does that makes sense?
AUDIENCE: OK.
Because of the even odd?
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah.
Yeah.
Any other questions on this?
Does anyone want
to see this again?
Yeah?
So I could let this run for
the rest of the lecture,
but I have more
interesting material
that I want to talk about.
So let's just stop
after this finishes.
And as you see again,
the looping code
is slowly making
its way to the top.
It's much slower than
the trapezoid code.
OK.
So that was only
for one dimensions.
Now let's look at what
happens in two dimensions.
And here, I'm going
to show another demo.
And this demo, I'm actually
going to run the code for real.
The previous demo was
just a simulation.
So this is going to
happen in real time.
And I'm going to simulate
the heat in a 2D space.
And recall that the colors
correspond to the temperature.
So a brighter color
means it's hotter.
So let me pull out
the other demo.
OK.
So here, my mouse cursor
is the source of heat.
So you see that it's making the
points around my mouse cursor
hot.
And then it's slowly diffusing
its way to the other points.
Now I can actually move this
so that my heat source changes,
and then the heat I generated
earlier slowly goes away.
OK.
So in the lower
left hand corner,
I'm showing the
number of iterations
per second of the code.
And we can see that the
looping code is taking--
it's doing about 1,560
iterations per second.
Let's see what happens when we
switch to the trapezoid code.
So the trapezoid code is
doing about 1,830 iterations
per second.
So it's a little bit
faster, but not by too much.
Does anyone have an idea why
we're seeing this behavior?
So we said that
the trapezoid code
incurs many fewer cache
misses than the looping code,
so we would expect it to
be significantly faster.
But here it's only
a little bit faster.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JULIAN SHUN: Right.
So that's a good point.
So in 2D you're
only saving a factor
of square root of M instead
of M. But square root of M
is still pretty big
compared to the speed
up we're getting here.
So any other ideas?
Yeah.
So there is a constant factor
in the trapezoidal code.
But even after accounting
for the constant factor,
you should still see a
better speed up than this.
So even accounting for
the constant factors,
what other problem
might be going on here?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is it that we don't
actually have an ideal cache?
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah.
So that's another
good observation.
But the caches that
we're using, they still
should get pretty good cache.
I mean, they should still
have cache complexly
that's pretty close to
the ideal cache model.
I mean, you might be off
by small constant factor,
but not by too much.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Maybe
because [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN SHUN: Sorry.
Could you repeat that?
AUDIENCE: There are [INAUDIBLE]
this time like [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah.
So OK.
So if I move the
cursor, it's probably
going to be a little bit slower,
go slower by a little bit.
But that doesn't really
affect the performance.
I can just leave my cursor
there and this is what
the iterations per second is.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Maybe there's like,
a lot of similar programs
doing this [INAUDIBLE].
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah.
So there is some other
factor dominating.
Does anyone have an idea
what that factor might be?
AUDIENCE: Rendering?
JULIAN SHUN: No.
It's not the rendering.
I ran the code without
showing the graphics,
and performance was similar.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Maybe similar to what
she said there could be other
things using cache [INAUDIBLE].
JULIAN SHUN: Yes.
Yeah.
So there could be other
things using the cache.
But that would be true
for both of the programs.
And I don't actually have
anything that's intensive
running, except for PowerPoint.
I don't think that
uses much of my cache.
All right.
So let's look at why
this is the case.
So it turns out that the
hardware is actually helping
the looping code.
So the question is how
come the cache oblivious
trapezoidal code can have
so many fewer cache misses,
but the advantage gained
over the looping version
is so marginal?
Turns out that for
the looping code,
the hardware is
actually helping it
by doing hardware prefetching.
And hardware prefetching
for the looping code
is actually pretty good,
because the access pattern
is very regular.
It's just going
one row at a time.
So the hardware can predict
the memory access pattern
of the looping code,
and therefore, he
can bring in the cache lines
that the looping code would
need before it actually gets to
that part of the computation.
So prefetching is
helping the looping code.
And it's not helping
the trapezoid code
that much because the access
pattern is less regular there.
And prefetching does
use memory bandwidth.
But when you're using
just a single core,
you have more than
enough bandwidth
to take advantage of
the hardware prefetching
capabilities of the machine.
But later on, we'll see that
when we're running in parallel
the memory bandwidth
does become more
of an issue when you
have multiple processors
all using the memory.
Yeah?
Question?
AUDIENCE: Is there a way of
touching a cache [INAUDIBLE]
or touching a piece of memory
before you need it so that you
don't need [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN SHUN: You can do
software prefetching.
There are instructions to
do software prefetching.
Hardware prefetching is
usually more efficient,
but it's like less flexible
than the software prefetching.
But here we're not
actually doing that.
We're just taking advantage
of hardware prefetching.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah.
So we didn't actually try that.
It could benefit a little
bit if we used a little bit
of software prefetching.
Although, I think it would
benefit the looping code
probably as well if we did that.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is hardware
prefetching [INAUDIBLE]??
JULIAN SHUN: Sorry?
Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Is hardware
prefetching always enabled?
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah.
So hardware
prefetching is enabled.
It's always done by the
hardware on the machines
that we're using today.
This was a pretty
surprising result.
But we'll actually see the
fact of the memory bandwidth
later on when we look
at the parallel code.
Any other questions
before I continue?
OK.
So let's now look at the
interplay between caching
and parallelism.
So this was a theorem that we
proved in the previous lecture.
So let's recall what it says.
It says let Q sub p
be the number of cache
misses in a deterministic
Cilk computation
when run on p processors,
each with a private cache,
and let s sub p be the
number of successful steals
during the computation.
In an ideal cache model
with a cache size of M
and a block size of
B, the number of cache
misses on p processors
equal to the number of cache
misses on one
processor plus order
number of successful
steals times M over B.
And last time we also said that
the number of successful steals
is upper bounded by the
span of the computation
times the number of processors.
If you minimize the span
of your computation,
then you can also minimize the
number of successful steals.
And then for low
span algorithms,
the first term is usually
going to dominate the Q1 term.
So I'm not going to
go over the proof.
We did that last time.
The moral of the story
is that minimizing
cache misses in
the serial elision
essentially minimizes them
into parallel execution,
assuming that you have
a low span algorithm.
So let's see whether our
trapezoidal algorithm works
in parallel.
So does the space
cut work in parallel?
Recall that the space
cut, I'm cutting it
with a slope of negative
1 through the center,
because it's too wide.
So can I execute the two
trapezoids in parallel here?
No.
The reason is that
the right trapezoid
depends on the result
of the left trapezoid.
So I can't execute
them at the same time.
But there is a way that I can
execute trapezoids in parallel.
So instead of just doing
the cut through the center,
I'm actually going
to do a V-cut.
So now I have three trapezoids.
The two trapezoid in black--
I can actually execute
those in parallel,
because they're independent.
And everything in
those two trapezoids
just depends on the
base of that trapezoid.
And after I'm done with the
two trapezoids labeled 1,
then I can compute
the trapezoid label 2.
And this is known as
a parallel space cut.
It produces two black trapezoids
as well as a gray trapezoid
and two black trapezoids
executed in parallel.
And afterwards, the
gray trapezoid executes.
And this is done
recursively as well.
Any questions?
Yeah?
No.
OK.
We also have the time cut.
Oh, sorry.
So if the trapezoid is
inverted, then we're
going to do this
upside down V-cut.
And in this case, we're going
to execute the middle trapezoid
before we execute the two
trapezoids on the side.
For the time cut, it turns
out that we're just going
to use the same cut as before.
And we're just going to execute
the two trapezoids serially.
So we do get a little
bit of parallelism
here from the
parallel space cut.
Let's look at how the
parallel codes perform now.
So, OK.
So this was a
serial looping code.
Here's the parallel
looping code.
So we had 1,450 before.
About 3,700 now.
So little over
twice the speed up.
And this is on a
four core machine.
It's just on my laptop.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
JULIAN SHUN: Sorry?
JULIAN SHUN: Oh yeah, sure.
Yeah, it's slowing down a
little bit, but not by too much.
OK.
Let's look at the
trapezoidal code now.
So as we saw before,
the trapezoid code
does about 1,840
iterations per second.
And we can paralyze this.
So now it's doing about
5,350 iterations per second.
So it's getting about a
factor of three speed up.
I can move it around a little
bit more if you want to see it.
So serial trapezoid
and parallel trapezoid.
Is everyone happy?
OK.
Because I had to do
this in real time,
the input size wasn't
actually that big.
So I ran the experiment
offline without the rendering
on a much larger input.
So this input is a
3,000 by 3,000 grid.
And I did this for 1,000 time
steps using four processor
cores.
And my cache size
is 8 megabytes.
So last level cache size.
So the input size here is much
larger than my last level cache
size.
And here are the
times that I got.
So the serial looping code
took about 129 seconds.
And when we did it in parallel,
it was about 66 seconds.
So it got about a
factor of two speed up,
which is consistent
with what we saw.
For the trapezoidal code, it
actually got a better speed up
when we increased
the input size.
So we got about a
factor of four speed up.
And this is because
for larger input size,
the cache efficiency
plays a much larger role,
because the cache is so small
compared to our input size.
So here we see that the
parallel looping code achieves
less than half of
the potential speed
up, even though the
parallel looping
code has much more
potential parallelism
than the trapezoidal code.
So trapezoidal code only had a
little bit of parallelism only
for the space cuts, whereas the
trapezoidal code is actually
getting pretty good speed up.
So this is near linear speed
up, since I'm using four cores
and it's getting
3.96 x speed up.
So what could be going on here?
Another thing to
look at is to compare
the serial trapezoid code with
the serial looping code, as
well as the parallel trapezoid
code with the parallel looping
code.
So if you look at the
serial trapezoid code,
you see that it's
about twice as fast
as the serial looping code.
But the parallel
trapezoid or code
is about four times faster
than the parallel looping code.
And the reason here is
that the harbor prefetching
can't help the parallel
looping code that much.
Because when you're running
in parallel, all of the cores
are using memory.
And there's a memory
bandwidth bottleneck here.
And prefetching actually
needs to use memory bandwidth.
So in the serial case, we had
plenty of memory bandwidth
we could use for a prefetching,
but in the parallel case,
we don't actually have much
parallel-- but much memory
bandwidth we can use here.
So that's why in
a parallel case,
the trapezoid code
gets a better speed up
over the parallel looping code,
compared to the serial case.
And the trapezoid code
also gets better speed up
because it does
things more locally,
so it needs to use less--
fewer memory operations.
And there's a
scalability bottleneck
at the memory interconnect.
But because the trapezoidal
code is cache oblivious,
it does a lot of work in
cache, whereas the looping code
does more accesses
to the main memory.
Any questions on this?
So how do we know when we have
a parallel speed up bottleneck,
how do we know
what's causing it?
So there are several main
things that we should look at.
So we should see if
our algorithm has
insufficient parallelism,
whether the scheduling
overhead is
dominating, whether we
have a lack of memory
bandwidth, or whether there
is contention going on.
And contention can refer to
either locking or true and
false sharing, which we talked
about in the last lecture.
So the first two are usually
quite easy to diagnose.
You can compute the work in
the span of your algorithm,
and from that you can
get the parallelism.
You can also use Cilkscale to
help you diagnose the first two
problems, because Cilkscale can
tell you how much parallelism
you're getting in your code.
And it can also tell you
the burden of parallelism
which includes the
scheduler overhead.
What about for memory bandwidth?
How can we diagnose that?
So does anyone have any ideas?
So I can tell you
one way to do it.
I can open up my hardware and
take out all of my memory chips
except for one of them,
and run my serial code.
And if it slows
down, then that means
it was probably
memory bandwidth bound
when I did it in parallel.
But that's a pretty heavy handed
way to diagnose this problem.
Is there anything we can
do was just software?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Can we simulate like
Valgrind would do it and count
how memory accesses [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah, so you
could use a tool like Valgrind
to count the number
of memory accesses.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: It's like
toolset or something
where you can make sure
that only one processor is
being use for this.
JULIAN SHUN: So you can make
sure only one processor is
being used, but you can't--
but it might be using
like, more memory
than just the memory
from one chip.
There's actually a
simpler way to do this.
The idea is that we'll
just run p identical copies
of the serial code.
And then they will all
executing in parallel.
And if the execution
slows down, then that
means they were
probably contending
for memory bandwidth.
Does that make sense?
One caveat of this
is you can only
do this if you have enough
physical memory, because when
you're running p
identical copies,
you have to use more DRAM
than if you just ran one copy.
So you have to have
enough physical memory.
But oftentimes, you can usually
isolate some part of the code
that you think has a
performance bottleneck,
and just execute that
part of the program
with p copies in parallel.
And hopefully that
will take less memory.
There are also
hardware counters you
can check if you have root
access to your machine
that can measure how
much memory bandwidth
your program is using.
But this is a pretty
simple way to do this.
So there are ways to diagnose
lack of memory bandwidth.
Turns out that contention
is much harder to diagnose.
There are tools that exist
that detect lock contention
in an execution, but usually
they only detect a contention
when the contention
actually happens,
but the contention
doesn't have to happen
every time you run your code.
So these tools don't detect a
potential for lock contention.
And potential for
true and false sharing
is even harder to detect,
especially false sharing,
because if you're using a bunch
of variables in your code,
you don't know which of those
map to the same cache line.
So this is much
harder to detect.
Usually when you're trying to
debug the speed up bottleneck
in your code, you would first
look at the first three things
here.
And then once you eliminated
those first few things,
then you can start looking
at whether contention
is causing the problem.
Any questions?
OK.
So I talked about
stencil computation.
I want to now talk about
another problem, sorting.
And we want to do this
cache efficiently.
OK.
So let's first analyze
the cache complexity
of a standard merge sort.
So we first need to analyze
the complexity of merging,
because this is used as a
subroutine in merge sort.
And as you recall
in merging, we're
given two sorted input arrays.
And we want to generate
an output array that's
also sorted containing all the
elements from the two input
arrays.
And the algorithm is going to
maintain a pointer to the head
of each of our input arrays.
And then it's going to
compare the two elements
and take the smaller one
and put it into the output,
and then increment the
pointer for that array.
And then we keep doing this,
taking the smaller of the two
elements until the two
input arrays become empty,
at which point we're
done with the algorithm.
We have one sorted output array.
OK.
So to merge n elements, the time
to do this is just theta of n.
Here n is the sum of the
sizes of my two input arrays.
And this is because I'm only
doing a constant amount of work
for each of my input elements.
What about the number
of cache misses?
How many cache misses will incur
when I'm merging n elements?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah.
So I'm going to incur
theta of n over B cache
misses because my two input
arrays are stored contiguously
in memory so I can
read them at B bytes
at a time with just
one cache miss.
And then my output array
is also stored contiguously
so I can write
things out B bytes
at a time with just
one cache miss.
I might waste to cache line at
the beginning and end of each
of my three arrays, but
that only affects the bound
by a constant factor.
So it's theta of n over B.
So now let's look at merge sort.
So recall that merge sort has
two recursive calls to itself
on inputs of half the size.
And then it doesn't
merge at the end
to merge the two sorted
outputs of its recursive calls.
So if you look at how
the recursion precedes,
its first going to divide the
input array into two halves.
It's going to divide
it into two halves
again again, until
you get to the base
case of just one element,
at which point you return.
And then now we start merging
pairs of these elements
together.
So now I have these arrays
of size 2 in sorted order.
And I merged pairs
of those arrays.
And I get subarrays of size 4.
And then finally, I
do this one more time
to get my sorted output.
OK.
So let's review the
work of merge sort.
So what's the recurrence
for merge sort
if we're computing the work?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah.
So that's correct.
So I have two subproblems
of size N over 2.
And then I need to do theta
n work to do the merge.
And this is case two
of master theorem.
So I'm computing log base b of
a, which is log base 2 of 2.
And that's just 1.
And that's the same as
the exponent in the term
that I'm adding in.
So since they're the same, I
add in an additional log factor.
And my overall work is
just theta of n log n.
OK.
So now I'm going to solve
this recurrence again using
the recursion tree method.
I'm still going to
get theta of n log n.
But I'm doing this
because it's going
to be useful when we analyze
the cache complexity.
So at the top level I
have a problem of size n.
And I'm going to branch into
two problems of size n over 2.
And when I'm done
with them, I have
to do a merge, which
takes theta of n work.
And I'm just putting n here.
I'm ignoring the constants.
And I'm going to branch again.
And each one of these is going
to do n over 2 work to merge.
And I'm going to get all
the way down to my base case
after log base 2 of n levels.
The top level is doing n work.
Second level is
also doing n work.
And it's going to be the
same for all levels down
to the leaves.
Leaves is also doing a
linear amount of work.
So the overall work is just
the work per level times
the number of levels.
So it's just theta of n log n.
OK.
So now let's analyze
this with caching.
OK.
So we said earlier that
the cache complexity
of the merging subroutine
is theta of n over B.
And here's the
recurrence for the cache
complexity of merge sort.
So my base case here is when
n is less than or equal to cM,
for some sufficiently
small constant c.
And this is because
at this point,
my problem size fits into cache.
And everything else
I do for that problem
is still going to be in cache.
And to load it into
cache, the base case,
I need to incur theta
and over B cache misses.
And otherwise, I'm going to have
to recursive calls of size n
over 2.
And then I need to do
theta of n over B cache
misses to do the merge
of my two results.
So here, my base case is larger
than what I did for the work.
The algorithm actually
is still recursing down
to a constant size base case.
But just for analysis, I'm
stopping the recursion when
n is less than or equal to CM.
So let's analyze this.
So again, I'm going to
have the problems of size n
at the beginning.
And then I'm going to split into
two problems of size n over 2.
And then I'm going to
have to pay n over B cache
misses to merge the
results together.
Similarly for the
next level, now I'm
paying n over 2B cache misses
for each of my two problems
here to do the merge.
And I keep going down until
I get to a subproblem of size
theta of cM.
At that point, it's
going to fit in cache.
And I don't need to recurse
anymore in my analysis.
So number of levels
of this recursion tree
is just log base 2 of n over cM.
So I'm basically chopping off
the bottom up this recursion
tree.
The number of levels I had
below this is log base 2 of cM.
So I'm taking a log base
2 of n and subtracting
log base 2 of cM.
And that's equivalent to log
base 2 of n divided by cM.
The number of leaves I have
is n over cM since each leaf
is state of cM large.
And the number of cache
misses I need to incur--
to process a leaf is
just theta of m over B,
because I just need to load
the input for that subproblem
into cache.
And then everything
else fits in cache.
So for the top level,
I'm incurring n
over B cache misses.
The next level, I'm also
incurring n over B cache
misses.
Same with the third level.
And then for the leaves, I'm
incurring m over B times n
over cM cache misses.
The n over cM is
the number of leaves
I have and theta of m over
B is the number of cache
misses per leaf.
And that also equals
theta of n over B.
So overall, I multiply
theta of n over B
by the number of levels I have.
So the number of levels I have
is log base 2 of n over cM.
And I just got rid
of the constant
here, since doesn't affect
the asymptotic bound.
So the number of cache misses I
have is theta of n over B times
log base 2 of--
or any base for the
log of n over M.
So any questions
on this analysis?
So I am saving a factor of
B here in the first term.
So that does reduce.
That just gives me a
better cache complexity
than just a work bound.
But for the M
term, it's actually
inside the denominator
of the log.
And that doesn't actually
help me that much.
So let's look at how
much we actually save.
So one n is much greater than
M. Then log base 2 of n over M
is approximately equal
to log base 2 of n.
So the M term doesn't contribute
much to the asymptotic costs,
and therefore,
compared to the work,
we're only saving
a factor of B. When
n is approximately equal to
M, then log base 2 of n over m
is constant, and we're
saving a factor of B log n.
So we save more when
the memory size--
or when the problem
size is small.
But for large enough
problem sizes,
we're only saving
a factor of B. So
does anyone think that we
can do better than this?
So I've asked this question
several times before,
and the answer is
always the same.
Yes?
It's a good answer.
So we're going to do this
using multiway merging.
So instead of just merging
two sorted subarrays,
we're going to merge
together R sorted subarrays.
So we're going to have R
subarrays, each of size
n over R. And these are sorted.
And I'm going to
merge them together
using what's called
a tournament tree.
So how the tournament
tree works is I'm
going to compare the heads of
each pair of these subarrays
and store it in the node
of the tournament tree.
And then after I do that,
I compare these two nodes.
And I get the
minimum of those two.
Eventually, after I compare
all of the elements,
I'm just left with
the minimum element
at the root of the
tournament tree.
And then I can place
that into my output.
So the first time I want to
fill this tournament tree,
it's going to theta of
R work because there are
R nodes in my tournament tree.
So when I compare these two
elements, the smaller one is 6.
For these two, the
smaller one is 2.
And then I compare 2 and
6, take the smaller one.
And then on the other
side, I have a 7 here.
So I compare 2 and 7.
2 is smaller, so it
appears at the root.
And then I know
that that's going
to be my minimum element among
the heads of all of the R
subarrays that I'm passing it.
So the first time to
generate this tournament tree
takes theta of R work because
I have to fill in R nodes.
But once I generated
this tournament tree,
for all subsequent rounds, I
only need to fill in the path
from the element that one
to the output or right,
or to the root of
the tournament tree,
because those are the only
values that would have changed.
So now I'm going to
fill in this path here.
And this only takes theta
of log R work to do it,
because the height of
this tournament tree
is log base 2 of R.
So I'm going to fill this in.
Now 14 goes here.
6 is a smaller of the two.
And then 6 is a smaller
of the two again.
So my next element is 6.
And I keep doing this until
all of the elements for my R
subarrays get put
into the output.
The total work for
merging is going
to be theta of R
for the first round,
plus n log R for all
the remaining rounds.
And that's just equal
to theta of n log R,
because we're assuming that
n is bigger than R here.
Any questions on how the
multiway merge works?
No?
OK.
So let's analyze the
work of this multiway
merge when used
inside merge sort.
So the recurrence is
going to be as follows.
So if n is 1, then we just
do a constant amount of work.
Otherwise, we have R
subproblems of size n over R.
And then we're paying theta of n
log R to do the multiway merge.
So here's the recursion tree.
At the top level, we
have a problem of size n.
And then we're going to split
into R subproblems of size n/R.
And then we have
to pay n log R work
to merge the results of the
recursive call together.
And then we keep doing this.
Turns out that the
work at each level
sums up to n log base 2 of
R. And the number of levels
we have here is log base R
of n, because each time we're
branching by a factor of R. For
the leaves, we have n leaves.
And we just pay
linear work for that,
because we don't have
to pay for the merge.
We're not doing anymore
recursive calls.
So the overall work is
going to be theta of n log
R times log base R of n,
plus n for the leaves,
but that's just a
lower order term.
And if you work out the
math, some of these terms
are going to cancel
out, and you just
get theta of log n for the work.
So the work is the same
as the binary merge sort.
Let's now analyze
the cash complexity.
So let's assume that
we have R less than cM
over B for a sufficiently
small constant C less than
or equal to 1.
We're going to consider the
R way merging of contiguous
arrays of total size n.
And if R is less than
cM over B, then we
can fit the entire
tournament tree into cache.
And we can also fit one block
from each of the R subarrays
into cache.
And in that case, the
total number of cache
misses to do the multiway merge
is just theta of n over B,
because we just have to go over
the n elements in our input
arrays.
So the recurrence for the R
way merge sort is as follows.
So if n is less than cM,
then it fits in cache.
So the number of cache misses we
pay is just theta of n over B.
And otherwise, we have R
subproblems of size n over R.
And that we add
theta of n over B
to do the merge of the
results of the subproblems.
Any questions on
the recurrence here?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So how do we
pick up the value of R?
Does it make it cache oblivious?
JULIAN SHUN: Good question.
So we didn't pick
the value of R.
So this is not a cache
oblivious algorithm.
And we'll see what to choose
for R in a couple of slides.
So let's analyze the cache
complexity of this algorithm
again, using the
recursion tree analysis.
So at the top level, we're going
to have R subproblems of size
n over R. And we have
to pay n over B cache
misses to merge them.
And it turns out that at each
level, the number of cache
misses we have to pay is n over
B, if you work out the math.
And the number of levels
of this recursion tree
is going to be log
base R of n over cM,
because we're going
to stop recurring
when our problem size is cM.
And on every level
of recursion, we're
branching by a factor of R. So
our leaf size is cM, therefore
the number of leaves
we have is n over cM.
And for each leaf, it's going
to take theta of m over B cache
misses to load it into cache.
And afterwards, we can
do everything in cache.
And multiplying the number of
leaves by the cost per leaf,
we get theta of n
over B cache misses.
And therefore, the
number of cache
misses is n over B times
the number of levels.
Number of levels is
log base R of n over M.
So compared to the binary
merge sort algorithm,
here we actually have a factor
of R in the base of the log.
Before, the base of
the log was just 2.
So now the question is what
we're going to set R to be.
So again, we have
a voodoo parameter.
This is not a cache
oblivious algorithm.
And we said that R has to be
less than or equal to cM over
B in order for the
analysis to work out.
So let's just make it
as large as possible.
Let's just set R equal
to theta of M over B.
And now we can see what this
complexity works out to be.
So we have the total
cache assumption.
We also have the fact that
log base M of n over M
is equal to theta
of log n over log M.
So the cache complexity is
theta of n over B times log base
M over B of n over M. But if we
have the tall cache assumption
that log base M over B is
the same as log base of M
asymptotically.
So that's how we get
to the second line.
And then you can
rearrange some terms
and cancel some terms out.
And we'll end up with theta
of n log n divided by B log M.
So we're saving
a factor of theta
of b log M compared to
the work of the algorithm,
whereas for the binary
version of merge sort,
we were only saving a factor
of B for large enough inputs.
So here we get another factor
of log M in our savings.
So as I said, the binary one
cache misses is n log n over B,
whereas the multiway one
is n log n over B log M.
And as longest as n is
much greater than M,
then we're actually saving much
more than the binary version.
So we're saving a factor
of log M in cache misses.
And let's just ignore the
constants here and look at what
log M can be in practice.
So here are some
typical cache sizes.
The L1 cache size
is 32 kilobytes,
so that's 2 to the 15th.
And log base 2 of that is 15.
So we get a 15x savings.
And then for the
larger cache sizes,
we get even larger saving.
So any questions on this?
So the problem
with this algorithm
is that it's not
cache oblivious.
We have to tune the value of
R for a particular machine.
And even when we're running
on the same machine,
there could be
other jobs running
that contend for the cache.
Turns out that there are
several cache oblivious sorting
algorithms.
The first one that was
developed was by paper
by Charles Leiserson, and
it's called funnel sort.
The idea here is to recursively
sort n to the 1/3 groups of n
to the 2/3 elements, and
then merge the sorted groups
with an n to the 1/3 funnel.
And this funnel is called
a k funnel, more generally,
and it merges together k cubed
elements in a k sorted list.
And the costs for doing
this merge is shown here.
And if you plug this
into the recurrence,
you'll get that, the
asymptotic number of cache
misses is the same as
that of the multiway
merge sort algorithm while
being cache oblivious.
And this bound is
actually optimal.
So I'm not going to
have time to talk
about the details of the
funnel sort algorithm.
But I do have time
to just show you
a pretty picture of what
the funnel looks like.
So this is what a k
funnel looks like.
It's recursively constructed.
We have a bunch of square
root of k funnels inside.
They're all connected
to some buffers.
So they feed
elements the buffer,
and then the
buffers feed element
to this output square root
of k funnel, which becomes
the output for the k funnel.
So this whole blue
thing is the k funnel.
And the small green triangles
are square root of k funnels.
And the number of cache misses
incurred by doing this merge
is shown here.
And it uses the tall cache
assumption for analysis.
So a pretty cool algorithm.
And we've posted a paper online
that describes this algorithm.
So if you're interested
in the details,
I encourage you to
read that paper.
There are also many other cache
oblivious algorithms out there.
So there's been
hundreds of papers
on cache oblivious algorithms.
Here are some of them.
Some of these are also
described in the paper.
In fact, I think all
of these are described
in the paper we posted.
There are also some cool cache
oblivious data structures
that have been developed,
such as for B-trees,
ordered-file maintenance,
and priority queues.
So it's a lot of literature
on cache oblivious algorithms.
And there's also a
lot of material online
if you're interested
in learning more.